The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All
right, so I'll start
with this review board, which
shows the conservation law.
Scalar, one unknown,
one dimension,
x, one space variable, and
the flux function is f of u.
That's the differential form.
We have seen that at some
points that differential form
produces a discontinuous
solution, a discontinuity.
In that case we
are better off with
the integrated integral form.
So I just integrate that one
from a point x_left to a point
x_right, from an a to
b, and that gives me-- I
have then the integral.
So if u was density,
for example,
the integral of density
will be the mass.
That's the quantity
that I'm seeing here,
so this is the rate
of change of mass
in the interval comes from flux
going out minus flux coming in.
So that's the conservation
law in its pure statement.
And we learned that
solution for this--
while we're looking at
the differential problem,
we can follow these
characteristics
from the initial time zero.
So at time zero we look
at a point x and the value
at that point just
travels-- is sort of safely
carried up the characteristic
line, which is that equals x_0.
And the problem arose when
characteristics either collided
into each other or separated.
Those are the two
difficulties and they
have different resolutions.
So this is what we met
in the traffic example
when a light goes red.
When a light goes red cars
are coming up to the light,
in front of the light
the density is low.
The cars have to brake quickly.
So something happens--
that's a question mark there.
What do you do when
characteristics collide?
When the value here cannot
be both the initial value
that's coming up that
characteristic and the initial
value that's coming up there
because they're different?
So we need a rule
for what to do there.
And we also need a
rule for what to do
in case of an empty space.
When no characteristics--
here, two characteristics
are hitting, here none
are touching there.
Characteristics are separating
in this case and the question
is, what solution do
you fill in the middle
when you haven't got
a characteristic?
It's not coming from the start.
OK, what solution to choose?
The answers will be different.
And let me take the first one,
the collision question, first.
So what will happen
is a shock will form.
There'll be a shock line so
that these characteristics carry
information into the shock, by
the way, that's a big deal--
up until they hit the shock,
and these characteristics
carry their information.
And across the shock we
have different values,
u on the left and
u on the right.
So that's one possible
form of the solution
because that will solve
the equation in this region
where the characteristics
from the right
are following the formula.
It'll solve it from the left,
so everything comes down
to the jump condition
at the shock.
What's the shock speed?
Where does this shock go?
It's to find that
shock in the xt-plane
that I have to use
this integral form.
I must use the integral
form because I've
got a discontinuity and
the differential form just
doesn't make sense.
OK, I wrote down the key idea
here or the conclusion, but not
the reasoning.
I'm looking for
this jump condition
at the shock, which is
going to locate the shock.
And the key quantity
that I have to find
is the shock speed,
which will tell me
where that shock is going,
how it's moving up in time.
So time is going that way, x is
going this way in this picture.
So this has a speed, s of t.
And here's the conclusion.
There's the jump condition.
So what does it mean?
This notation, this bracket
notation is the jump.
The shock equation is beautiful.
It says that s, the shock
speed, times the jump
in u is the jump in f of u.
And let me take
this example that
is sort of the Burgers'
equation example.
So this is the example that
comes from Burgers' equation.
That's the example
where the flux
is this nice parabolic
function u squared over 2.
Then the change in flux, the
jump in the flux function
is u right squared minus
u left squared over 2
and I divide by the jump in u,
which is u_right minus u_left
and that cancels
beautifully and leaves me
with the 1/2 of
u_right plus u_left.
It tells me that the shock speed
is exactly halfway between.
It's exactly the average,
in this Burger's example,
of the characteristic
speed from the right
and the characteristics
speed from the left.
And notice, it's in between.
That's crucial.
That tells us that
this figure is good.
It tells us that characteristics
are entering the shock
from both sides.
Characteristic lines
are entering the shock.
The shock is somehow, in
this sort of nonlinear case,
it's somehow kind of cutting
out bits of the solution,
reducing the energy,
reducing the entropy,
reducing the total variation
as we'll see it in a minute.
So that's the answer here and
I guess I have to justify,
where did this come from?
Well, it came from
this integral form.
Suppose I integrate
from a little bit
to the left of the
shock to a little bit
to the right of the shock.
Of course, that's where I
want to integrate in order
to capture the shock.
OK, so if I just
take that equation
and write it over here, and
I'll imagine-- because I'm not
going to be-- x_left and x_right
are going to be pretty near
the shock-- u up to the
shock will pretty much
have a constant value u_left.
So approximately, that
is the shock position.
Let me say the shock
is at-- capital
X is the position of the shock.
So I have x minus x_left times
u on the left of the shock.
I'm doing that integral.
Oh, I need d by dt of all this.
So d by dt.
It's d by dt of the
integral of u dx.
Let me just put here
what I'm computing.
I'm computing that
from x_left to x_right.
Well, I'm going up
to x, up to capital
X where the shock
is, and then onward.
So here I went up to x
using the value u left.
And now will be the
onward part, which
will be x_right minus x, the
half of the interval that's
on the right of the
shock, times u right.
And then copying this term is
exactly our jump in f of u.
Plus the jump in f of u is zero.
Those words, total variation
are a reminder to myself
for what comes next.
OK, so is that OK?
That will be approximately
zero because u wasn't exactly
constant on the left and right.
It didn't stay at the
value u_L but we're
squeezing the
interval down where
it's essentially constant.
OK, so now, just look
and see what we've got.
dx/dt is the shock speed, so
that's s, multiplying u_L,
and here I have-- the
derivative of that is zero,
the derivative of x_R is zero.
Here I have a minus,
so it's minus u_R.
dx/dt times that number plus the
jump in f of u, left to right,
is 0.
And that's our equation.
If I put this on
the opposite side
it becomes u_right minus u_left.
Shall I do that?
So I'll keep this on this
side, got a good sign,
but I'll move this
onto the other side
so it will be the shock
speed, d capital X dt times
u_R minus u_L, which
is the jump in u.
So that's great.
We now have a way to deal
with shocks that collide.
So that was a derivation of
this jump condition, which first
had a name, two authors Rankine,
Hugoniot in gas dynamics,
but then it was seen
as the right condition
in all conservation laws.
OK.
And now I'm ready to
comment on the second issue.
What do you do when
characteristics separate?
Well, let me say
what you don't do.
You could, without
wrecking the equation,
you could try to
put a shock in there
and give this the
value u on the left,
even though a
characteristic isn't
telling us what's going on
in this space or this one.
You could try to put
a shock in there.
You could maybe satisfy
the jump condition
if you put the right shock in,
but the characteristics would
be coming out and that's wrong.
And it's called the
entropy condition, which
says that this can't happen.
That the derivative of
entropy has a certain sign
and it rules this out.
It rules out this possibility
of characteristics
emerging from the shock and
we need a totally different
solution.
And it turns out to
be a fan in there.
So we put in a fan
of characteristics
coming from here and that
gives a solution that actually
will depend on x over t.
This solution will be a
simple-- a simple ratio x over t
enters that.
In other words, that gives
us a smooth solution,
and I guess, thinking about
the traffic example, that's
exactly what happens.
So this is the shock part.
Now for the fan
part, what happens
when we have a bunch of cars
sitting there, ready to go?
The light goes green, the
first cars start moving,
cars behind them see the car in
front moving, they start moving
and so the initial profile
would be, in this case,
for cars, would be high
density and then zero density.
So this would be maximum density
sitting at the light and zero
density in front of the light
and then the light goes green
now and what happens?
Well, as we all know those
first cars pull ahead
and the profile is these cars
haven't yet started to move.
These have started to
move and there's a profile
there and then zero density.
So this represents the
first car, the lead car.
In front of that car is zero
density and that's the fan.
That's the x over t expression.
So a simple linear expression,
which will flatten out;
as time goes on, these cars
will be going faster and faster
and then eventually
up to full speed.
OK, so that's the fan.
Maybe now is my chance to
speak about this concept
of the variation in a function.
The idea will be now, how do
we get the finite difference
method to do this automatically?
Well, OK, one way to do it
is put in a little viscosity.
This rule, the rule that picks
out this shock in one case,
of colliding
characteristics, and this fan
in the case of separating
characteristics, one way
to get to those
two solution would
be to put in a little
bit of viscosity
and then let epsilon go to zero.
And the result would
be these two solutions.
And in a way, that's what finite
differences is going to do.
Finite difference
or finite volume
is going to be a
numerical viscosity
and the epsilon in
the Burgers' equation
would become delta t or a delta
x in the numerical method,
in the finite
difference equation.
And then what's the concept?
So we have to find
finite differences.
And we want those-- the
point is finite differences
sort of takes more care.
We can't just create
something that's
consistent in the smooth case.
Up till now we've just
had no hesitation.
We replaced derivatives
by differences
without too many
worries, really.
And that was fine as long
as the solution is smooth.
But now if we're going
to replace derivatives
by differences, we have
to do it in such a way
that this entropy
condition, these solutions
emerge automatically.
And really, in a way that--
our finite difference
or our finite volume
methods should somehow
conserve mass the same way
the true equation does.
So those are two
different points.
First point is this
question of total variation.
What's the total
variation in a function?
Well, let me draw a function.
The total variation
is-- well, let me see.
Total variation in a
function u is going to be,
by definition, the integral of
the absolute value of du/dx.
OK now we have to
understand this concept.
It's beautiful that the analysis
has led to a quantity as simple
as that, as a guide.
So when we create finite
difference methods we will ask,
are they total
variation diminishing?
So TVD will be total
variation diminishing methods.
Methods where this quantity
does not increase in time.
Let me just understand
this quantity first.
The absolute value is crucial.
If the absolute
value was not there,
then I would just have the
integral of the derivative,
so it would be u at that
point minus u at that.
But here I'm taking absolute
values, so for a while
the derivative is
positive, up to there.
So the integral gives me
this value minus this.
Then, in this region, the
derivative is negative,
but I'm taking absolute value.
Do you see that that
integral will split
into four separate integrals?
The total variation will be this
difference plus this difference
plus this plus this.
I'll have four--
in this example--
have four positive
contributions to the variation.
And that's the key
quantity there.
And what a shock
will do-- can I maybe
mention in this figure what
a shock does, can do, would
be to somehow cut out
part of the variation.
When a shock occurs it might
happen that these things are
going into the shock,
these are going
in from that side, and
the shock kind of jumps
from this value, u_left,
to this value, u_right,
following the shock
condition when it emerges.
And this additional
variation is wiped out.
You see that the variation
for the solution that
contains a shock is still--
this part is still there,
but this part is all
downhill, so it's just this.
It's that minus that.
And the middle two
parts have been cut out.
OK, so that's the total
variation in a function.
Let me just take the
most important example
that's not total variation
diminishing, which
is Lax-Wendroff.
The one-- even in
the linear case.
The one experiment we've done
with that profile, where,
you remember, we had a wall of
water and the exact solution
brought the wall to the left
with velocity c, with speed c,
but Lax-Wendroff,
which did quite well
staying near the
discontinuity, near the jump,
had a little oscillation behind.
That was essentially our one
objection to Lax-Wendroff,
was that oscillation showing up.
And so that's telling us
that the variation-- see,
the variation in the true
solution is just that step.
The variation in the
Lax-Wendroff answer
is this bigger
step plus this one
plus this one plus
this, larger than 1.
Roughly the match is that
monotone methods-- so here's
the general picture.
We can get monotone, or I'll
say, all positive coefficients,
and those will be total
variation diminishing.
Great.
Why don't I draw--
recall a monotone example
was Lax-Friedrichs or upwind.
Upwind will be our model, so
let me draw the upwind one.
The upwind one didn't increase
the variation, it stayed at 1.
We had no oscillations,
but it was low accuracy.
So first order.
We can't do better than
first-order accuracy, the order
of accuracy I'm measuring in
the smooth part of the solution
because that's where I can take
Taylor series and match terms
and see which is the first
one that doesn't match.
And Lax-Friedrichs and
upwind was first order.
Then our problem is that if I
allow a negative coefficient
then variation increases,
oscillations will come in,
but I can get the accuracy
up to second order or higher.
And Lax-Wendroff is the
example, the key example
there that I'll continue with.
OK, that's the idea
of total variation.
It just gives us
a quantity to work
with when we see oscillation.
And of course, I'm
interested in oscillations,
so this is a linear case
with a discontinuity.
I don't think it's quite
fair to call it a shock.
At least, the
shocks that we meet
in conservation laws in
the nonlinear problems,
they're created--
the ones we saw here
are created for nonlinear
reasons, colliding
characteristics, whereas the
linear case has characteristics
all parallel.
So here, we're in
the lecture, we're
really into the second lecture
into the scientific computing
part of our problem.
So that's the analysis
part, the PDE part.
Now comes the experience of
quite a lot of people working
hard to identify a way to get
second-order accuracy where
it's smooth and monotonicity
or something like it
where the shocks are.
So that's essentially the goal.
Our method is going to
turn out to be nonlinear.
It's going to have some--
it'll be called a flux limiter.
The key quantity
will be the flux.
And for a smooth function
when u_right and u_left are
very close, the flux is small,
we don't have a problem.
But at a shock where there's
a significant jump in u
and especially in f
of u, the flux limiter
is going to come in,
into the discrete method.
Let me begin discrete
methods with a new word,
finite volumes.
And with a new
interpretation of capital U.
So the discrete value,
capital U_(j, n), which,
up to now we've been thinking
of as that's an approximation
to the true solution,
at j delta x, n delta t.
Now, because we're dealing
with discontinuities,
we better integrate.
We integrate over
a delta x interval.
We take the average over
a little delta x interval
instead of hitting
just the point.
So the delta x interval from
j minus 1/2 to j plus 1/2,
we take the average of
u at the time n delta t
and that's what finite volume--
and let's think of as capital
U, the discrete approximation.
The appropriateness of that
is in the integral form
of the conservation law.
So the integral form
of a conservation law
leads us to that natural
discretization, d by dt of U,
of the average.
You're keeping your eye
on the integral form
of the conservation law.
I'll just come back to it again.
The derivative of the
mass, the integral
of u-- so in the discrete case,
the difference of capital U--
plus the integrated
term of flux at one end
of the interval minus a
flux at the other end.
And notice that we are
getting for the flux, half--
so a staggered grid is
presenting itself naturally.
And so that
f_(j+1/2), the fluxes,
which is the critical thing,
is on the j plus 1/2 grid.
All right, now this
could be exactly defined
as the flux at that grid point.
Capital U squared over 2
in the Burger equation,
at that grid point.
That would give us a totally
straightforward, first-order
numerical method.
First order, I see
first order here in time
and it might be better
than that in space
because in some way
that's centered.
But if we want higher
accuracy, if we
want to include
Lax-Wendroff, for example,
that includes
several values of u,
we go to a more
general flux function.
The whole job here is create
a smart flux function.
So a flux function depends not
only on u in the center, u_j,
at time n-- this
is all at time n--
it can also depend on
values to the left of it
and values to the right.
It may use those
values, it may not,
but we allow that
possibility then,
that the flux-- so this
is the numerical method
that you aim for.
Is to choose a flux
function and of course,
this should be consistent
with the original problem
and that simply says that if
all the u's were the same,
that the numerical flux
function would give you the flux
function in the given equation.
OK, so this is our
general pattern.
And now, the question is
really, maybe the first step
is write a-- I would like to
write upwind and Lax-Wendroff--
I'd like to find
their flux functions.
I guess I'm saying
that when we look
at an equation in
this format, we
can take methods that
we have already used
and see, OK, even in the
linear case, the one-way wave
equation, what are we picking
for the flux function?
OK, now the one distinction
is: the one-way wave equation,
we had a constant, and
upwind, for example,
went in the direction
decided by that speed, c.
If the speed reversed sign
so that the waves were going
the other way, the wind
is coming the other way,
the upwind direction
is the other way,
so our method would change.
Let me just write
down the flux function
that turns out to
come for upwind
and then for Lax-Wendroff.
OK, so for upwind the
flux turns out to be--
F turns out to be 1/2
of-- because it's at this,
this is f_(j+1/2), really.
It's at the center point.
The flux function will be--
I'll put in the a-- a delta t--
sorry, a over 2 U_(j+1)
plus U_j, now, plus--
or rather minus actually--
comes absolute value of a over 2
times u_(j+1) minus u_j.
If we're patient we can track
down the two cases, a positive
and a negative, and recognize
that this form switches
direction correctly on
the difference method.
So it keeps us upwind,
in other words.
If the wind changes
direction our flux
changes appropriately to
follow that direction.
So that's an OK flux function.
It's a monotone one
and it's first order.
Now let me put in Lax-Wendroff.
What would Lax-Wendroff be?
Would be the same, the same
upwind flux, if I call that UP
for upwind and
then a correction,
a Lax-Wendroff term that gets
the second-order accuracy.
OK, and that turns out to be--
it turns out that I multiply
this term by that ratio r.
By the absolute value of r.
So it turns out that it's--
the Lax-Wendroff thing,
to get that extra accuracy,
you might remember,
had an extra delta
t over delta x.
And so it's this same
thing times a over 2.
In the nonlinear case
it'll be f of u_(j+1).
f at u_(j+1) minus f at u_j.
Next time, I'll come
back to this point
and pin down this
more carefully.
All I want to do
in completing today
is introduce this idea
of a flux limiter.
So what people say when
they look at Lax-Wendroff
is that this term
that's been added on
is fine in the case
of a smooth solution,
but in that case of a
jump, like our picture
here, that term is
increasing variation.
It's an anti-diffusion term.
Instead of smoothing things
out the way F upwind does,
that extra term has the
effect of increasing the jump.
It's anti-diffusive.
And therefore, when
it's a significant term,
the flux limiter
cuts back on it.
The result will be
a numerical method,
which is not linear
anymore even if we apply it
to a linear problem.
The result won't
be strictly linear
and it will produce
a profile that
doesn't have that oscillation.
So it has what we want.
It gives us good answers
when the solution is smooth,
it stays near the shock
the way Lax-Wendroff does,
but it doesn't oscillate.
OK, so what's the flux limiter?
The flux limiter is, I multiply
in here by some function,
the limiter function, phi_(j+1)
and I multiply in here
by phi_j.
In other words, there's
an extra factor,
this flux limiting factor.
So the question is,
how to construct that?
What formula do we use
for the flux limiter?
So the flux limiter,
after lot of experiments
is chosen to depend on--
so we want it to be 1.
So what do we want?
We want it to be 1 or
close to 1 at smooth part
and we want it to be greater
than 1 at a discontinuity.
OK, so our question
is, how do you
identify that discontinuity?
Well, the convenient
way has turned out
to be look at the ratio--
look at differences.
Look at the ratio of--
so what comes in here
will be the ratio
r, say, j plus 1/2.
That'll be the ratio of U,
say j plus 2 minus U_(j+1) 1
to U_(j+1) minus U_j.
All at time n.
That ratio tells us--
that ratio is close to 1,
if-- so the ratio r is close to
1 for smooth and our function,
phi of r then, we want our
function phi, when the ratio is
1, to give the value 1.
So if I try to draw
a graph of-- let
me draw a graph of people's flux
functions-- of the phi of r.
So here's a graph of phi of r.
First on the graph I'll
put upwind and Lax-Wendroff
without anything.
So Lax-Wendroff would take-- phi
Lax-Wendroff is identically 1.
This is the ratio
r and this is phi.
So Lax-Wendroff, before fixing,
had no flux limiter function
and it just had 1.
And actually, if I can
keep the same formula,
phi_upwind would just be zero.
Then it'll turn out that--
let me draw these ratios.
There is a region here and
here where the flux limiter
is doing the right thing.
So in that region it's
acting the right way.
It's limiting the
anti-diffusive flux.
It's controlling the variation.
It's controlling
the oscillation.
So various people have
proposed-- let's see.
No, I haven't got this right.
I think it's-- because I
know that part is wrong
for Lax-Wendroff.
So maybe it's there.
No, I've forgotten--
sorry that I'm
not-- I've lost this because
I know that one possibility is
this as the flux limiter.
One possibility
would be this one
and then there's
another possibility that
is OK that goes through here.
Let me stop for today with
this idea of a flux limiter
and you see that it's a
task to fix the method
to do the right
thing at smooth parts
and also the right thing
at discontinuities.
OK, I'll pick up
on that next time.
Thanks.